today we reached political agreements in
Echo Finn on the deck for dossier which
is about cooperation between tax
administration's country-by-country
reporting as part of our work on the
anti tax avoidance package presented by
the Commission in January we've all
shared the view that the compromise is
acceptable so no further technical work
on the text is required once adopted and
enforce this directive well as of 2016
oblige the large multinational companies
to file country-by-country reports to
Texas authorities and this information
will then be automatically exchanged
between member states this will permit
to have a clearer picture about
potential transfer pricing risks that
business activities of such large
company groups may generate we also
reached an agreement in the council
conclusions on the transparency and the
efficiency of the code of conduct group
which is also about tax policies as you
know the council conclusions call for
having more substantial six-monthly
group reports to echofon reflecting the
main elements and views which were
discussed under specific tax items and
the council conclusions also invite the
code of conduct group to explore
initiatives to further inform the public
on the results of its meetings and the
chair of the code of Colonel grouped is
asked to report to echofon and the other
institutions in person more frequently
little difficult tax fairness is not to
be seen as just an option that's why 28
of Jeremy lasa presented ambitious
proposed lumbus and today we show that
Europe can move forward quickly and
effectively if all the parties concerned
move together in the same direction